>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS,
THANK YOU.
TURMOIL IN THE STREETS OF
VENEZUELA TODAY AS PROTESTERS
DEMAND PRESIDENT NICOLAS MADURO
STEPPED DOWN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS TAKING THE CLEAREST STEP YET
TO SHOW HIS SUPPORT.
HE ANNOUNCES THE U.S.
RECOGNIZING THE HEAD OF THE
OPPOSITION CONGRESS AND
VENEZUELA IS THAT COUNTRY'S
LEADER.
DESPITE THE PEOPLE, HE IS NOW
WITHOUT HIS SUPPORTERS AND IS
CLAMPING DOWN TONIGHT.
STATE AS        STATE DEPARTMENT
STATE AS        STATE DEPARTMENR
STATE AS        STATE DEPARTMEND
STATE AS        STATE DEPARTMENO
STATE AS        STATE DEPARTMENN
STATE AS        STATE DEPARTMENH
STATE AS        STATE DEPARTMENS
THE LATEST.
>> ACROSS VENEZUELA, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PROTESTERS
DEMANDING NICOLAS MADURO GET
OUT.
>> I FELT THAT PEOPLE ARE
BELIEVING AGAIN.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
OPPOSITION LED NATIONAL
ASSEMBLY, EARLIER THIS WEEK HE
BEGAN A LEGAL PROCESS TO TRY TO
REPLACE HIM.
TODAY, I SWEAR TO FORMALLY
ASSUME THE POWERS OF THE
NATIONAL EXECUTIVE AS PRESIDENT
IN CHARGE OF VENEZUELA.
>> THE UNITED STATES AGREES, THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED HIM AS THE INTERIM
PRESIDENT OF VENEZUELA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS, I WILL
CONTINUE TO USE THE FULL WEIGHT
OF THE UNITED STATES ECONOMIC
AND DIPLOMATIC POWER TO PRESS
FOR THE RESTORATION OF THE IN A
SPILL IN DEMOCRACY.
WE HOLD HIM RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY
THREATS IN A POST OF THE SAFETY
OF THE PEOPLE.
>> HE SAYS HE IS BREAKING
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS WITH THE
U.S. GIVING AMERICAN DIPLOMATS
72 HOURS TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS LITTLE INDICATION THAT
HE PLANS TO LEAVE.
>> WE HOPE THAT NICOLAS MADURO
LOOKS UP TO PEACEFUL TRANSITION.
>> THAT HE WILL ACCEPT THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE.
TO MOVE THIS COUNTRY FORWARD AND
EMBRACE THEIR NEW PRESIDENT.
>> AT THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN ASKED
WHETHER THE U.S. WOULD CONSIDER
USING MILITARY FORCE THERE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFUSED TO ROLL
IT OUT.
>> WE ARE NOT CONSIDERING
ANYTHING, ALL OPTIONS ARE ON THE
TABLE.
>> THE GOVERNMENT IS BEST TO
RELEASE TO THE DEMONSTRATION,
THEY FIRED RUBBER BULLETS AND
TEAR GAS, PRO-GOVERNMENT
FACTIONS ALSO ORGANIZE COUNTER
PROTESTS.
>> THE GOVERNMENT THAT MADE
CHAVEZ, THE GOVERNMENT THAT HAS
NICOLAS MADURO HAS ACHIEVED
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION ENCOURAGES
OTHER GOVERNMENTS TO JOIN THE
U.S.
NICOLAS MADURO HAS CALLED THE
OPPOSITION, LITTLE BOYS UNDER
THE CONTROL OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THE UNITED NATIONS SAYS
3 MILLION VENEZUELANS HAVE LEFT
THEIR COUNTRY, ESCAPING RAPID
INFLATION, FOOD AND MEDICINE
SHORTAGES, AND VIOLENCE.
SEVERAL ALLIES IN THE REGION
HAVE 20 ADMINISTRATION AND
RECOGNIZING ONE WHITE OUT AS THE
INTERIM PRESIDENT OF ONE
ESCUELA, THE DEFENSE
MINISTER INDICATES THE